هذان الشخصان لا يستطيعان الإقلاع عن بعضهما البعض
عندما يتعلق الأمر بالعروض العامة
للعاطفة ، شكرًا لك ، شكرًا لك ، لقد
أحصل على غرفة بالفعل في المكتب البيضاوي
عندما يشكرك صديقك الخاص ،
شكرًا لك ، شكرًا
للرئيس ترامب والرئيس ماك
لم يتصافح الكروم فقط ، بل كان عليهم
إضافة ربتة أو يد على ظهرهم بالتناوب
حتى مقبض الصندوق الذي حدقوا به في
عيون بعضهم البعض وتمتم بأشياء حلوة ،
شكرًا لك باستخدام الأسماء الأولى يا
عزيزي السيد دونالد.  أنا والرئيس شيريدان إلدون
إيمانويل نتحاور من رواية عن علاقة
غرامية ، آمل أن تشعر بنفس
الطريقة التي
تستعد لها ، لكنك لم ترَ
هذا من قبل أحد قادة العالم
يهيئ الآخر ، لكن لدينا علاقة خاصة جدًا
في الواقع سأحصل على ذلك
قطعة صغيرة من قشرة الرأس ، أوه ، علينا أن
نجعله مثاليًا في صحيفة فرنسية واحدة
تسمى الإيماءة المزعجة ، لاحظنا
مات زحف لاحقًا أثناء فحص المواقع ،
الرئيس ترامب
فلينت ، السيدة الأولى التي كان من الصعب الوصول إليها ، قامت
قبعتها بمحاولات للتعبير عن
قبلة أكبر من المعتاد على تويتر.  ناقدًا قال
إن القبعة تسمى قبعة ترامب الطاردة
أثناء تصويرهما للصور
، بدا أن الرئيس وميلانيا يلعبان
القدمين بأصابعهما التي استخدمها برنامج The
Daily Show للموسيقى ،
لكن الرؤساء لم يتمكنوا من
فصل أيديهم عن كل المعانقات التي تركتهم
صفعة جدًا-  يسعدني أن أتصل بك يا
صديقي أن الرئيس ترامب فاته
صفعة قطع الاتصال الفرنسي النادر لهذين
[موسيقى]
جنيف CNN news
you